yeah yeah I take it so when you say
you're making a rock project what kind
of rock are we talking about it's rappy
Rock it's like Limp Biscuit Fred Durst
Limp Biscuit but it's more so [ __ ] I'm
a [ __ ] so I got the gang bang in there a
little bit I twisted it up you know what
I'm saying we dressing up me and still
is going crazy with that shout out to
steals great guys shout out steals man
he's a sweet kid he's a good kid he's
also a grown up he's a nice little kid
he's a grown man they're a nice kid
Stills is a grown-up
I feel like I've known him for like 10
years he's a nice gentleman yeah yeah
he's a nice gentleman
and he loves designers so much he got a
tattooed on his body good grades in
school nice boy no I love stuff now you
guys have developed like a dope uh just
working relationship and in terms of
like
I feel like
steals has been on a run as well as
yourself yes you guys you know doing
joint projects and [ __ ] together
definitely definitely do you feel like
there's a difference when you go that
approach and you lock in solely with
like a Steals and when you do
just different producers oh yeah for
sure is it Stills I'm in there with the
[ __ ] cooking up the magic making it we
laughing giggling my order some chicken
wings or something like that with other
producers it's like yeah send me a pack
bro bet I'm over there bam boom it's
done I can create that from scratch with
steals though yeah you know what I'm
saying which one do you prefer
steals yeah Stills over anybody honestly
because we just get in there and we Just
Vibe like bro I need something with
pianos then I'll explain to the [ __ ]
what I want like I need something that's
gonna make me feel like Geppetto
swallowed as in a well stomach
and it's dark and I want to feel
evil
what does that sound like
or I'll tell the [ __ ] I want to be I
want to feel like I'm a lost Native
American Indian trying to find my tribe
while pilgrims and settlers are trying
to kill me [ __ ] just go go crazy
and he'll make the sound I'll be like
[ __ ] that's what I was looking for Wow
[ __ ]
oh [ __ ] which song is that is it out
it's not out it's not out yet we got
some [ __ ] [ __ ] we got some [ __ ] hmm you
know uh yeah I was he wasn't expecting
see that [ __ ] just kind of just was
quiet right there
that's amazing I'm just in my head I'm
like how does that what does that sound
like getting swallowed by a whale yeah
sounds like I'm a dice you are familiar
with the Pinocchio story though uh dude
I I you got kids though that kid lied
and he grew a nose and he's not a real
boy and there was dude I [ __ ] was not
a Pinocchio guy I was watching The Lion
King and and um I feel he's Tarzan and
[ __ ] I saw you just posted a [ __ ]
photo with Tarzan
that's the one thing about me I'm always
just myself as you should be I'm just
and it's a lot and I know it's a lot of
people like I'll meet some of these
rappers and recording artists and when
when you meet them like right for the
first time it's like
what's up bro yeah we gotta work
yeah hell yeah my [ __ ] I just been
chilling yeah hit my line bro yeah and
then when I really start to die chop it
up with these [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] my
favorite Pokemon when I was younger was
it's like okay that's the real Yuka
that's the real you you know what I'm
saying it's like [ __ ] got this facade
about them and it's like when you break
Beyond it it's like damn could just be
you just do you you know I'm saying if
you like Disney [ __ ] if you like
Teletubbies [ __ ] I don't give a [ __ ] if
you like putting on red wigs and be a
clown my [ __ ] do you bro you you gonna
be alone in that casket
um yeah no I mean I see it all the time
you'll see like you'll meet a rapper and
you'll be like all right you got your
[ __ ] rapper Persona going right now
it's always a thing you know what I'm
saying it's crazy especially La guys
like if they're around their homies and
[ __ ] and it's like a rapper environment
you're like oh God we get it like bro I
understand you got 17 [ __ ] with you
[ __ ] have face tats you got the same
shirt on the chains I get it you're
you're slouching your pants sagging on
your ass my [ __ ] I will beat you up
like I'll beat you up for real
and I'll put on and I'll put on
Pinocchio at home with my girlfriend